bonjour ou voici de ces bons résultats
alors donc de bon ton que bien alors il
paraît qu'on est dans le making-of de la
science de l'amour avait déjà pensé
mettre fidèles possessif souverainement
par être amer
des choses à cacher
indemnités chose à thaçi je vais
proposer de réaliser un court métrage et
là on s'est rencontré il m'a raconté
cette histoire de quantifier l'amour et
j'aimais bien l'idée d'avoir un truc un
peu de ram est aussi un truc de coûts
c'est vraiment intéressant en fait parce
qu'on avait à chaque fois des réunions
pour essayer de rendre les armes en le
tout meilleur faire en sorte que ce soit
le plus efficace possible et on se
plaisent tous les deux dans le court
métrage que le court métrage me plaisent
ouais voilà c'est la fin de la france
n'a donc personnage de milo
à un moment un peu charnière de sa vie
où il va se marier avec avec sa copine
ça fait longtemps que son ensemble et là
ce fond de jalousie et paranoïa et peu
de répliques par exemple c'est tout bête
mais comme ça se passe beaucoup dans sa
tête et tout et qu'il a du mal sur
l'engrais ouais ouais
et en plus c'est le mariage va arriver
donc elle se dit ok c'est pas grave il
est dans sa phase de parano mais je vais
garder jusqu'au mariage tout seul mais
il est tellement insistant est tellement
relou finalement que craque et que c'est
donc là la scène finale où l'explosion
elle débite tout en fait sur le
personnage de flora bien sûr dans notre
tête c'était vraiment cette personne
toujours positive quelqu'un qui a
toujours le sourire et qui l'idée
c'était que elle elle freine tout elles
ne disent rien et que la relation soit
plein de non dits en fait mais toi tu
descends tout vers le bas
tellement de fois que abandonné sa
traque est très compatible
moi je vois ça comme un truc quand même
de douceur encore dans ce pan dans le
jacc d'année jours de tournage et à
partir de l'après midi ma seule réplique
que je vais faire c'est à dire
sean bean je vous le mets là il aussi
lancé un des anneaux sean penn schoen
bin voila c'est bon vous et profitez de
cette réplique pendant cinq heures jeudi
que cette phrase à tchernobyl
c'est ça qu'on a travaillé cinq
heures c'est le gros gros business
julien un moment donné
[Musique]
j'insère est parti c'est une chance
aurait bondi et sans cesse alors moi je
suis 2 le personnage du docteur dans
l'histoire il se fait un peu surprendre
à son propre jeu il a lancé sa effet pas
trop malin parce qu'elle vient de briser
un couple on imagine une sorte de
chercheurs quelqu'un qui est vraiment
beau c'est un peu toute sa vie sur
comment quantifier les émotions tout la
dernière partie pour la fin jusqu'au
revealed on va le suivre un peu plus on
va se mettre de son point de vue ils se
rendent compte pas que tout part en
vrille et que c'est pas une très bonne
idée
on a eu combien de décor si vous n'êtes
décors différents belle une dizaine une
dizaine de décor il ya eu des petits
décors par exemple quand on fait un
essayage ou même dans la voiture où ça
va assez vite
en tout les endroits clés c'est surtout
face à d'attenté la salle du thelle
salle d'attenté salutaire donc c'est ça
c'est tout l'univers de l'aspect
technologique en fait de cette histoire
de ce que la société s'appelle love 40
mais tout ça nous on voulait que ce soit
graphique
donc on est dans une sorte de petit
système qui sert à prendre en photo à la
base des visages sous tous les angles
un studio qui fait ça pour le cinéma le
jeu vidéo et nous on s'en sert en
détourne ça pour faire comme si c'était
une petite ambiance de tête ce jeu est
ce qu est une société technologique qui
est spécialisée dans la création et
l'animation de double au numérique
c'est-à-dire des modèles 3d venons
l'outil mise pour reproduire l'apparence
et le jeu de célébrités sur les films le
jeu vidéo considérer ces 6
on a pu avoir accès en fait à des
patterns qui qui nous on connait on a
une sorte d'interface ici et on peut
choisir ce qu'on resserre donc à chaque
fois qu'il y avait une réponse à la
question si je voulais en faire un flash
je passais same sex match mais la caméra
non la caméra mais à paris c'est inouï
pas au sol paraît si elle est cachée
juste là eh oui 1 puis c'était sûr et
surtout on est à l'espace niemeyer est
en fait le siège du parti communiste qui
a une architecture très particulière il
eu pas mal de tournage ici le film au
poste de quentin dupieux il ya eu pas
mal de clips et de publicité l'idée
c'était d'avoir un côté un peu un peu
trop pital psychiatrique
la rave c'était beau le dire à tout un
aspect bureaucratique avec les tests la
manière de l'expliquer les dossiers
c'est combien de la formule ces 1500
euros celle en trois mois la abbas et
celle ci 1500 euros ah non la formule
express près la scène de dîner on a
droit quand sur la serrure 10 fermes
pour accentuer voilà c'est ce côté où on
appuie sur sur certains points que milo
semble voir que qui semble anodin en
fait avec une milo sur analyse
ce qui est assez amusant c'est qu'on a
totalement déstructuré le scénario
pendant le montage on a des séquences
qui est des qu'il était censé apparaître
dans le vert le début du film finalement
être par exemple à trois minutes du film
qui finalement apparaît seins 13 minutes
du film on a juste et plein de petits
trucs comme ça pour que l'élément
déclencheur arrive plus tôt et la parano
soit plus longue c'est ce qu'on appelle
la troisième écriture sakho débutera
donc tu écris ton histoire situe la
réécrit un peu avec les comédiens sur
tourneur et puis ensuite au montage tool
a réécrit encore une nouvelle fois en
changeant peut-être en raccourcissant
les lacets sont en train de faire et
aussi la musique est très importante
sous les eaux commencent à intégrer la
musique aussi c'est un moment très
satisfaisant dans le montage rajoute
aussi les intentions dans la musique qui
est composée par différents c'est une
quatrième écriture jeudi mais oui c'est
vrai c'est une quatrième écriture parce
que ok on a eu
on a un moment où je sais pas quel car
il est en train de tuer une personne si
tu mets une musique qui racontent ce
moment et qui était peur parce qu'il est
en train de tuer la personne
finalement ça ne fait qu'accompagner la
scène et c'est pas si oui il ya
intéressant que ça c'est une musique
plus douce tu peux dire ah tiens il ya
du regret donc c'est afin de faire si tu
mets un truc drôle tu dis ah mais
peut-être pas vraiment mort c
et c'est un cochon donc c'est vrai c'est
une quatrième j'étais l'écriture c'est à
dire que cette les superbes tournage
presque aussi super enrichissant de
d'écrire des histoires que j'ai pas
besoin d'imaginer un gros big up à toute
l'équipe à trous à tout le monde et
aussi aux internautes qui ont suivi
cette petite aventure dramatique
[Musique]